- I wanna welcome everyone
to this session of Endeavors,
which is the department colloquium
for African-American Studies
here at Yale University.
I'm on Jacqueline Goldsby,
I'm chair of the department
and on behalf of our faculty,
our graduate students,
our undergraduate students, and staff
I wanna welcome everyone here.
It's exciting to see faces and
names that I don't recognize
and that's exactly the kind of outreach
we want to accomplish with this series.
Since I wanna say a couple of things
about the series itself, what it is,
what's on deck for us this semester,
the remainder of the semester
and a couple of reminders
about Zoom etiquette,
how we're going to be running
this particular session.
I'll start that now by
saying, as you all are now,
probably your mics are muted
and we'd ask you to keep your mics muted
throughout the discussion today.
It's okay, as some of you are doing
to keep your videos turned off.
Zoom fatigue is real and the
important things to be engaged
with your mind and your thinking
and which leads to the
third Zoom etiquette point
that we will be using
the chat very actively
during this session
that will be the conduit and
in our other hosts today.
Professor Crystal
Feimster will explain this
in a little bit more detail,
but I just want to say now,
that we'll be using the chat function
to talk with one another.
You can post ideas, thoughts,
questions, reflections.
If you want to pose a question
directly to our speaker today,
you would send that question
or query that comment
to Professor Feimster through the chat.
But those are some of the ground rules
for our discussion today.
But again, Endeavors is
the department colloquium
for African-American Studies.
And for those of you who are
with us for the first time
there are two hallmarks to our colloquium.
First of all, we all gathered together
because instead of
separating out our colloquium
according to subfields,
we understand our work in black studies
to be interdisciplinary.
So we deliberately have one
forum where we bring together
leading critics, scholars,
artists, activists,
to present work in progress,
work that they are doing right now,
so that when they come
together and think with us,
we can help them sharpen
their ideas, their practice,
the projects that they're engaged in
and we in turn can bring their
methods, their questions,
their energy to the work we're doing
in our own respective fields.
So two hallmarks about this colloquium.
It's about work happening
now, and it's in progress,
and it's about interdisciplinarity.
This semester, the
theme of our colloquium,
typically we allow ourselves
to kind of range across
the field of black studies
and to invite who's ever
doing the most exciting work
that we want to think with.
But given the exigencies
that we face right now,
the ways in which we are
rake reckoning, right?
This is the term with all of the ways
in which race has made an
unmade the modern world
and the particular face
of black people within it.
We are deciding to focus our attention
on what it means to be black
now and to think about,
and to hold conversations towards
the change, the revolution
that needs to happen in so
many different areas of life
of one of which will take place
in two weeks on November 3rd
with the election.
And so we've organized a
whole series of conversations
to think about those pressing areas
where scholarship and
action come together.
For those of you who
were with us last month,
we started off with Natasha Brown,
who's a voting rights activist
and her work with Black Voters Matter
which is absolutely pivotal
for the moment we're in.
And the ways in which she
actually offered us a new theory
of thinking about electoral participation
and doing that work she
was literally trans,
holding her conversation with us on a bus,
traveling through North Carolina
going to another voter registration event
was absolutely scintillating
and we'll soon have that
discussion posted online
for you to listen to and think with.
Today, we're going to be
focusing on the politics
of mass incarceration and health justice
with our guest a physician,
activist Dr. Emily Wang
who Professor Feimster we'll
introduce in just a moment.
And I just wanna call
attention to the fact
that we have three more events lined up
for the rest of the semester.
You can register for these events
on our department's website.
These events will be held on
November 9th, November 19th,
and December 10th
where we will be continuing
these discussions around
for instance, the role of art as protest.
How art pleads freedom
with the painter activist
Titus Kaphar and with the poet lawyer,
I won't say Laureate, but he's a lawyer.
Reginald Dwayne Betts.
We will have two sessions
on the politics of policing
with our new colleague,
Social Psychologist Phillip Atiba Goff
through his work for the
Center for Policing Equity
that will be on November 19th
and then on December 10th,
another of our new colleagues
Elizabeth Hinton who's a historian
and one of our long time
allies in the law school,
Tracey Meares, we'll be
talking about the work
that's happening at the Yale Law School's
Justice Collaboratory.
So invite everybody who's here today
to sign up for those events,
you can go to our department website
and register for those Zoom links.
I wanna take a couple more minutes here
to thank the Collaboratory, so to speak
that's organized and running this series.
Our principal co-sponsor
is the Center for the
Study of Race Indigeneity
and Transnational Migration
and it's director, Stephen
Pitti, Professor Stephen Pitti
and the Assistant Director Matthew Tanico
had been absolutely
indispensable in helping us
to organize and to mount this series
and I really wanna thank them
for their collaboration and their support.
I wanted to thank the
African-American Studies
Department Senior Administrative
Assistant, Vanessa Epps
who's done a tremendous job
working with Professor Crystal Feimster
getting the word out,
getting the series organized.
Thank you so much, Vanessa.
I also wanna thank our tech
support, Emmanuel Bissell.
I hope I'm pronouncing your
name correctly, Emmanuel.
He's keeping this room up and going,
so thank you so much, Emmanuel.
And finally, I want to
thank our chief curator
of this series, Professor
Crystal Feimster.
Now I can let it go
without saying how amazing
and brilliant and wonderful
Professor Feimster is
because many of us here have
the opportunity and the honor
of working with her every
day, taking classes with her
maybe three times a week.
But we have the chance to
work with her everyday,
but for those of you who don't know her
I just wanna make clear
that Professor Feimster
is one of the nation's
leading historians of USF
and a black feminist history.
Her award-winning book
"Southern Whores" transformed
how we understand post
reconstruction era racial violence
by excavating the
underknown histories of rape
as a tool of racial
domination along with lynching
and those divisive errors.
And she's increasing the
magnifying power of that analysis.
In her next book, she's
writing two of them
that examined the uses of sexual violence
in the U.S. Civil War.
These are gonna be game-changing books
and we're very lucky to have her bringing
that intellectual power
to organizing this series,
so I wanna thank her for her work.
And with that, I'll turn it over to her
to introduce our guest today.
- Thank you, Jackie, Professor Goldsby
for that lovely introduction.
And also thank you for making sure
that Endeavors continued this
term under all of the stress
and circumstances that we're all facing.
You were the one who said,
"We've gotta have these conversations."
And we in the department and
those in the Yale community
were more than willing to say,
yes to these conversations
and for all of us to kind of do this work
and be in this space together
in these difficult times
is really important.
So thank you for insisting on that
and leading us in having
these conversations.
I also wanna thank Vanessa.
I just wanna add to your note of gratitude
that Vanessa has sort
of come and new to FAM
and really rallied and
supported me in this series.
So thank you, Vanessa
and Emmanuel as well,
nothing but gratitude
for making this happen.
It wouldn't be happening
without the two of you,
so thank you.
I also want to thank
in advance racial man,
racial formation folks,
just because I'm putting you on the spot.
I know you're here.
This is part of like
your first year induction
into African-American studies
and we're glad you're here.
We wanna see you here,
we wanna hear your voice
and I'm hoping that you're gonna help me
amplify some of the
things that Professor Wang
is gonna share with us.
So when you hear her saying something
that you think needs to be repeated
or needs to be highlighted,
I want you to hit that up in the chat
and we'll repeat some of
the things that she says
and I'll ask questions
and have her go back
over some things for us,
because this is a moment for us
to really learn from Dr. Wang.
And so let's make sure that we highlight
what's important here.
On that note, What's important
is what Professor Wang
is gonna offer up to us today
and I wanna get that conversation going
and first I wanna introduce
Professor Wang or Dr. Wang.
So I have to say, I
actually have been sort of,
I don't wanna say stalking,
but following Dr. Wang for a while now,
both the professional
and the personal front.
Full disclosure, she
lives in my neighborhood
and she's got three daughters
who are the same age as my youngest Theia
and they were in Theia's
kindergarten class.
So everybody was like, who's
this person who's got triplets?
How is she doing this?
And then when I found out who she was,
I was like, Oh my God, she's amazing.
And I also first came across
you through your efforts
to Ban the Box, your work
around that and I really was,
it was one of those issues
that I had never thought of
and I remember when you
sent me an email about it,
I was just like, "Who is this
person, what is this issue?"
And so I had kind of
trapped you and followed you
and I'm so excited that
I get to introduce you to this community
both as like amazing community
person in my neighborhood,
but also as an amazing scholar.
So Dr. Wang is an associate professor
in the Yale School of Medicine
and directs the new Center
for Health and Justice
called SEICHE, I think I got it right,
but she will correct me if
I didn't and I'm sure of it.
The Center for Health and
Justice is a collaborative
between Yale School of
Medicine and Yale Law School
working to stimulate
community transformation,
identify the legal policy
and practice levers
that can improve the health
of individuals and communities
impacted by mass incarceration.
She also has the Health
Justice Lab that does,
which is a research program
which receives National
Institutes of Health funding
to investigate how incarceration
influences chronic health conditions
including cardiovascular disease, cancer,
and opiod use disorder
and uses a participatory approach
to studying interventions
which mitigate the
impact of incarceration.
And I wanna just sort of hit that again,
but she uses a participatory approach
and I think for those of you
who are coming out of
my civil rights course,
I think this is something I
want you to pay attention to.
And I want you to think
about some of the people
that we've been talking about,
Ella Baker and
"Participatory of Democracy"
and see what Professor Wang
is gonna tell us about that.
And finally, she's an internist
and she has cared for
thousands of individuals
with a history of incarceration
and is the co-founder of the
Transitions Clinic Network,
a consortium of 40 community
health centers nationwide
dedicated to caring for individuals
recently released from
correctional facilities
by employing community health workers
with histories of incarceration.
And I'm gonna leave it there
there's a lot more I could say.
It is on our flyer and she
does have an amazing website
that you can go to it that
links to many of her articles
that she's published on a range of topics.
And hopefully we'll get
to cover some of them,
but I know that we're not gonna
be able to cover everything
that she has her hands in,
but do check out her website
and the articles that she's published.
And on that note, I'm
gonna turn it over to Emily
to really introduce us
to herself and her work
and what the new center
is going to be doing
and how it builds on the work
that she's already been doing.
So welcome, Emily and thank you.
- Thank you.
You know, it's just a
deep honor to be here.
I have to say it's one of these things
when you're looking through your calendar
and I really I'm like
probably minute to minute now,
but at times week to week, I
just was so excited to be here.
It's always joyful to be in
conversation with Crystal
and in particular, for something entitled
Conversations for the
Revolution, sign me up.
And so, I think one of the
things that I'll start with today
is that I think it's critical,
there's not a lot of physicians
like there's not a lot of spaces
within the schools of medicine
where physicians are
talking about the revolution
and yet I think it's
critical to have physicians
and health systems really
actively engaged in this.
And in my world what this is increasingly
especially with young
students, younger students,
residents kind of more junior faculty
is talking about the
abolition of the police state
elaboration of the carceral state.
And the reality that I present
which is that those are all yes and true,
but I've had the opportunity
as a practicing physician
as Crystal has indicated
that you look at examples
right now of closing Rikers
and if you talk to physicians
that are practicing within Rikers
and they've had historic
drops in the jail population
that we could go into now,
so historic just with stupid, idiot,
easy changes that should have
long happened but haven't,
and then they finally did.
You can get the population
down from 13,000 to 11,000
to now it's 5,000,
but at the very end of the day,
there's probably about thousands of people
that won't be able to go home.
There's no place to go home,
there's no health system to care for them,
there's no place for them to live.
Our communities have entirely abrogated
their responsibilities at
the community health systems,
the housing systems, et
cetera, to those individuals.
And so in thinking about
dismantling a carceral state
and thinking about kind of
what abolition looks like
it requires a real deep reconstruction,
a real reckoning with the
social structures that do exist.
What does our social contract look like?
It's so fractured now that
we can't actually provide
for that space,
that we can't talk about kind of issues
of revolution and
abolition without saying,
that then you need an all
hands on deck approach
and folks like me within the health system
have to be on board.
And so it's in that space that I sit
and I'm often kind of intention,
which is the practicality
that every Friday,
Steph knows this, I see patients
that have just come home
from prison and jail.
And so that keeps it real
because there's a real reality
and individual with their family sometimes
and then certainly
returning into the community
where the resources are just limited.
And it's that space that you
can think really and truly
about what revolution looks
like, it's gonna be a process.
It's a long haul process
and it needs and requires
a interdisciplinary intersect or approach
to really thinking about how this looks.
So I'll start then by saying this,
that increasingly in my work
and Professor Goldsby alluded to this,
what I love most is being in
an interdisciplinary spaces.
We recently have a grant now actually
that we'll be looking at COVID-19
and I'll touch on this a little
bit within prisons and jails
and have an amazing opportunity
also to look at the history
of mass incarceration and pandemics.
And so Elizabeth Hinton
will be partnering on this,
we're gonna look at looking
at the legal barriers
and again, that's Tracey
Meares partnering on this.
To me, this is where it lies
is that if we do not have scholars
and also people that
have been incarcerated
and also people that are
currently incarcerated,
knee-deep in the solutions of the past,
knee-deep in what has worked in the past
and what just didn't get scaled up
and knee-deep on what we
are presented with now,
we're just not gonna get anywhere.
And so it's that place too
that I really like to be.
All right, so what I thought is usually
that this is Zoomland and
it's kind of terrible for me,
but usually what I usually do is to say,
try to answer the first question is like
why the hell is a doctor kind
of interested in this stuff?
And for me the place that's
easier for me to share with you
are just photos of prisons and jails
and what health systems look like,
just to give you a picture.
So I'll do a raise your hand,
and I'll just try to
quickly flash over my Zoom.
If you've stepped foot into
a prison or a jail before.
Okay, so good number
and then people aren't on it we got it.
And then what about, have you
been in a healthcare settings?
Okay, all right, Crystal her name's super.
So this will be somewhat
new to some of you
and then very new to others of you.
And so if there's terms and unfortunately,
once I share my screen
I can't see the chat,
but maybe I'll ask Crystal to stop me
if you feel like I'm
throwing out jargon, Crystal.
- Okay, I will.
- One of the places I'll
start part is just to share
that oftentimes people have,
and I think the media presents it poorly,
which is that the folks
who are incarcerated
that's 2.2 million individuals
and then we have a whole system
of community supervision,
but 2.2 million individuals
that are incarcerated
are this like young, healthy
lot that's able to exercise.
They're doing well, they
did a crime, they're inside
and the truth is that
that just isn't the case.
So the patient demographic,
and I frequently use the term patients,
they're not all patients,
but that is just my lens,
so I apologize for that.
But the patient demographic is changing.
The population behind bars,
given the incredibly
long sentences we've had
have meant that there's a
disproportionate proportion
of individuals that are 55 and older.
And when the last
estimates were looked at,
it's about 80% of individuals
within jails and prisons
that have a chronic health condition
that warrants longitudinal primary care.
So this includes like this
patient here who he's got COPD
and I shared these pictures just for you
to give a look at what
healthcare looks like.
They're waiting to see a doctor,
so there's one patient here
that's getting kind of an albuterol
like a treatment to help open his lungs
next to another patient
who has a mental illness
and he's in a cage.
So this is how healthcare
is structured behind bars.
And so when I say that about 80%
have a chronic health
condition, so for a range of,
what I mean is a range of conditions.
So high blood pressure,
asthma, COPD like this guy has
to also hepatitis C,
infectious diseases
like HIV and hepatitis C
to also depression,
post-traumatic stress disorder
schizophrenia, opioid use disorder,
all those conditions require, I'd say,
most physicians would say
a primary care doctor.
And so while we have the impressions
that folks are generally
healthy, in fact, they aren't
and they're aging behind bars
in systems that were never designed
to actually provide the health care
for chronic health conditions.
- Emily.
- Yeah.
- I'm curious, I'm thinking
about a few years ago,
there were black women in Alabama,
two sisters I think who
had like kidney failure.
I don't know if you remember this story,
but it seems to me that there was a moment
and I don't know if it's still the case
that around sort of decarceration
that was linked to the
economics of healthcare, right?
That in some of these States,
the Republicans and
more conservative people
were willing to think about decarceration
and reducing the number of
people who are incarcerated
because of health expenses
and the sort of cost of healthcare.
Is that something that has
happened or is happening?
- Yeah, that's a really
important point, so yes, it is.
I've been doing this for over a decade
and I'd say right now,
we're at a place of
increasing bipartisan support
that kind of whatever you call this.
The Carceral State Mass Incarceration
has been a failed policy
it hasn't changed violent crime rates
and also costs us too much.
So you'll see more right-leaning folks
or just blatantly right folks saying,
there's a whole right on crime, right?
That it's the costs of incarceration
that are what are driving,
is there animus for trying
to decarcerate our country.
But there is consensus
that the prison and jail
population is too big
and in large part these costs are driven
by healthcare costs, exactly
as you're pointing out
the aging your two sisters
with end-stage renal disease,
they cost and they cost
more in corrections
than they would in the community.
- [Crystal] Right, okay, thank you.
- And then, of course, and
especially thinking about COVID,
which we could talk about a little bit
because maybe that's my
work in progress right now
that we can touch on
that prison environments
can, of course, exacerbate poor health.
And I just want you to
think about the world
in which we're living right now, right?
We're masked, socially distance,
and think about these
individuals right here.
So all these pictures, I should say
come from California
Department of Corrections.
I actually did my residency
training in San Francisco
and had a longitudinal primary care clinic
within this prison in San Quentin.
And so, these pictures come from them
and I just use it to highlight
that it's incredibly overcrowded.
Again, our policies of mass incarceration
have led to situations like this,
where people are triple
bunking and gymnasiums
and then, of course,
in these circumstances
are hotbeds for COVID-19.
We can go into that for forever,
but you can only imagine
how you just can't socially
distance in places like this.
But also places where,
because of the stress
rates of cardiovascular disease,
we're hypothesizing are increasing.
So, there's a lot of work thinking about
kind of toxic stress
and what this looks like
and amped up stress responses
and in particular, what that
means for short-term health,
but also long-term health,
what that means for mental
health, but also physical health.
And so the actual environment,
they built environment,
but also the ways that
prisons and jails are defined
really kind of can magnify
different conditions in health.
And so what drew me to this is as follows,
so this blew my mind.
It's like I don't think
I would have ever been
like I was a primary care
doctor, thinking about medicine,
and I wouldn't have seen, if
you asked me 20 years ago,
would this be kind of
the focus of what I did?
It wouldn't have been, but prior
to the Affordable Care Act,
prisons and jails are one of
the only places in the U.S.
where healthcare is
constitutionally guaranteed.
And so what this meant for me,
it kind of is inconceivable,
but you'll see why this matters a lot.
There was a court case
in 1976 Estelle V Gamble
that kind of created the
constitutional rights
to healthcare behind bars.
Is that if you think about a population
that's 2.2 million people
that are incarcerated
who are disproportionately Black, Latino,
and a racial and ethnic
background of low income,
oftentimes, prisons and
jails are the first place
where individuals access
healthcare as adults.
This is where they learn,
this is where they experience,
this is where they meet
their first doctor,
this is where they understand
their chronic conditions,
and so this has significant bearing
for their kind of relationship
with the healthcare system,
their trust of the system.
You can imagine now in
COVID-19, their trust
and participating in any sort of issue
that is tied to healthcare,
healthcare system design.
And to me it also speaks to this,
which is that it has been a
place as you hear me go through
a place where people are first accessing
preventive health measures.
Actually do get treated for the first time
for hepatitis C in certain circumstances.
And so it's a conflicted
place personally I think
because we do such a
terrible job in the community
and because we have so many
Black and Brown people inside
that there is this perverse
kind of experience of healthcare
that starts in prisons and jails
and then gets transitioned home.
So if you look at our data and others,
about 40% of individuals
that are incarcerated
are newly diagnosed
with a chronic condition
while they're incarcerated.
- Emily, so since so many
young Black and Brown folks
are having for the first time
interacting with doctors,
I'm curious if you could
speak to who are the doctors,
what kind of doctors are
doing this kind of service?
Who are the doctors?
- You know, I actually think
Crystal it's like a mixed bag.
So in the news you're gonna hear,
it's like the problematic stories.
So people that are not
boarded in their specialty,
oftentimes it's like
misbehaving physicians
or criminal physicians, frankly
that have lost licensure, then
moved to a different state,
then have started a practice
within a correctional system,
and doing stuff out of licensure.
And also I would say that
there are also physicians
that commit to it because
they're kind of interested
in taking care of patients
that are more vulnerable,
really trying to think about this as,
and I'd say that's the younger
generation of physicians
that are more embracing
of kind of a more social justice vision,
but it's a mixed bag.
I also think you're
going to a place where,
if you think about
community health systems
there is an infrastructure
that protects you.
So, you Crystal when
you go to the hospital
and you're seeing a doctor
Yale New Haven Hospital,
you can rest assured
that there are certain kind of approvals
that have to be taken on
in order for that
hospital to get financed.
These are national guidelines
with a certain quality of care
that has to be delivered
in the health system,
otherwise they don't get the funding
from Medicaid, Medicare,
and private insurers.
Okay, so you can be certain of it.
There is no federal or
state mandatory oversight
of healthcare behind bars, period, none.
And so again, there's a heterogeneity,
so I don't wanna impugn colleagues of mine
that work inside doing the good work
and also you just don't know
what the work is, right?
It's like we have no way of knowing.
So when you go into
Yale New Haven Hospital,
you can rest assured that
it's been approved by Jayco.
When you go in here, there's
just no way of knowing.
And this is inherently the issue
which is that there's no
transparency, there's no kind of,
our taxpayer cash pays for
the care that's delivered
in Connecticut Department of Corrections
and you have no idea of knowing
if they're meeting the
standard metrics for quality,
nor do you know about
the quality positions.
- [Crystal] All right, okay, thank you.
- And so you know, I just highlight this
and maybe this photo is
better for physicians
and training our students
in the health allied professionals.
But you know again,
while there is this
constitutional access to care
it's just totally entirely different.
And so this was a patient that I had met.
He had just been diagnosed
with like a condition
where your blood pressure
is out of control,
it's so crazy that you
might be at risk for stroke.
It's called hypertensive emergency.
So we sent out to outside hospitals,
so they have to contract out, of course,
'cause most prisons don't
have their own hospital,
comes back in and this is
supposed to be the place
where he recuperates, okay?
So just to start, just look around,
I'm rounding as a physician
and everyone in earshot
correction officers there
that has the person right next to him
incarcerated as well as listening,
you throw the cuff through,
many of you probably have gone to a doctor
where they check a blood pressure.
This is not properly positioned,
he has to place it on yourselves
and you're kind of having a
DL conversation with them,
trying to see, what did you learn.
If you're the doctor in
there and there I was,
of course, there's drugs in there
and you wanna talk to them about things
that doctors would talk
about and you're not able to.
The other thing to just note is that
this patient will never
have to call a pharmacy
to get his meds, never even
have to give himself a reminder,
like the whole kind of how he
manages his chronic condition
for those of you are on
blood pressure pills.
What happens is that
every morning he's called
at the crack of dawn,
correctional officer wakes him up,
he goes and makes a line, his
cup is filled, it's a Medline,
he has to drink it
and then the nurse checks
to see if he's cheeked it
and then come and then he
makes it back to his room.
And so it's incredibly passive.
It's almost, but totally
paternalistic like it's childlike,
but adherence is 100%.
If you donate here, we've done
studies that have shown this.
For instance, let's say you're like
I'm not feeling like getting
an insulin injection today,
for whatever reason,
folks participants have stated in studies
that they've been sent
us all to a confinement.
And so there is this
entirely different notion
of how healthcare is delivered,
how it's administered,
how people see it, and how
people are punished for it,
within corrections that, of
course, doesn't translate
into the types of a
doctor-patient relationship
you wanna create.
The other thing too is that every time
this patient wants to see a doctor.
So in Connecticut, for instance,
for a chronic disease visit,
you have to pay three bucks.
So you're like, wow,
what's three bucks, right?
Well, three bucks is
equivalent to four days work
if you're lucky enough to have a job.
And so again,
there's just so many
different barriers that exist
for people that are incarcerated
to actually access care.
This picture I highlight,
so it's just pointing out this pink slip.
And so it's a kite that
patients have to fill out again,
when they wanna see a provider,
healthcare provider or doctor.
And so again, this is no
longer happening in California,
but it's still happening
all over the country.
The person fills it out
that then gets evaluated
by a correctional officer.
The correctional officer then decides
whether or not it's a
valid medical concern,
it goes to a nurse and then
it goes to a physician.
And so again, all sorts of
barriers to getting care.
This also is an HIV clinic
and so again, there's
just no confidentiality
again, there's a correctional
officer walking by.
Everyone in this line knows
that they're all going
to see the HIV doctor.
And so just the whole
notion that kind of values
that we hold true and are principled
in one's around human dignity and rights
are infringed upon and
infringed upon largely
a population that is of low
income and racial minorities
that again have rarely accessed
the community health system.
And then, I always show this picture
and for me this is just
the deep brutality,
the kind of the violence
that the health system
can exert on individuals.
And so, think about that first
patient that I showed you
the older gentleman that maybe
it's requiring oxygen now,
and this happened to be not the same guy,
but another patient who needs
chronic oxygen administration
for his COPD.
And you can just note here
that the oxygen's outside
his solitary confinement door.
And so, you would hear
him is when it changed
like bamming on the door.
And you'd walk by and
doctors would walk by
and I remember being a person in-training
being like, how's this permissible.
And it's because the values of safety,
really trump the values of
dignity, but of health, right?
And so there's many, many
different expressions of violence
that are just ingrained within the system
and are difficult to, of course, shake off
when people come home.
You wonder why there's
all sorts of notions
within medicine about noncompliance
and people that are
mistrustful and these people.
And then you think about this
and that's life preserving
to actually be mistrustful.
It's life preserving to not
kind of trust in health systems.
It literally is the smartest
and strategic thing that you can do.
And so, where my work kind of sits mostly
at this intersection, I'd say,
is that the vast majority of
you know, Jeremy Travis
said that nearly 95%
of individuals come home to the community
and that's about rights.
That for what it is,
we have 2.2 million in
and 95% folks will actually
end up coming home.
And so I think what is
the most interesting to me
is that it's actually
their health outcomes.
You know, if you compare what happens
when they're incarcerated
versus when they come home
are significantly worse
when people come home.
So you have about a 12 times
increased risk of dying
in the first two weeks, post release.
Big seminal study published
in New England Journal
of Medicine that showed
that the first most common
cause of dying is overdose,
but then heart disease,
homicide specifically.
Okay, there's homicide,
suicide, and cancer
and then other chronic conditions as well
and depending on what States
data you're looking at,
it's like hepatitis C cancer is from that.
But again, and it really
elevated risk of dying
in this first two weeks, post-release
a really elevated risk of hospitalizations
and not surprisingly, a worsening
of all chronic conditions.
And this is because we
have just so many barriers
to people coming home, right?
So inabilities to, as crystal mentioned,
you can't find a job because
you always have to check a box.
You cannot find a place to live,
there's a ban on food stamps.
You cannot find a place to live
because you you have a criminal record
and you can't live in public housing
or your family can't house you
because you have a criminal record
and it just goes on and on.
And so the real challenge
for us as a health system
is figuring out how better to
engage people who come home.
And so one of the things
that Crystal alludes too,
and I won't go into it much now,
but it's just that we are
using participatory approaches
about now 15 years ago
started a transitions clinic
program in San Francisco.
It's where I trained and really deeply
in partnership with people
that had been previously incarcerated.
There's a long civil rights
movement that is embedded there
that we partnered with all of us or none
and really created a program
that I think was centered
around the values,
preferences, and needs of people
with histories of incarceration.
And core among that,
and here's the picture
here on the right who's our
first community health worker
health community health workers
that are embedded within
primary care clinics
that have histories of
incarceration themselves.
And really, I think part of
what I've in doing this work,
I personally haven't been incarcerated.
Wen we started this program,
I'll say now we have like 45
programs all across the country
there are so many deep naysayers
like our whole science, our whole notion,
especially within health systems
is one about mitigating risks.
It's like all this stuff
is wrong in these people
and we just have to make
a more normal, right,
that there isn't a lot of value
and what we're really
trying to do as a community,
within transitions is
to change that narrative
is there's so much going right.
You know, there are lots of people
and assets within communities
that have been impacted
by mass incarceration
and that too should inform our science.
And so, through the years,
what we've been able to do
is using kind of the
best of impaired design,
using randomized controlled trials
show that Transitions Clinic Programs
actually does improve
healthcare utilization,
improves primary care,
it actually reduces future
criminal justice contact.
And so really trying to
shift the entire narrative,
which is that there is value
in also looking at what functions
well in these communities
and also then studying that to scale.
The second thing I'd say is that,
I'm just moving through these
pictures a little bit more
is that in seeing these patients over time
one of the things I've realized
is there's just not a lot
that's known about this population.
The science is terrible.
And I share with you this figure
from a paper that we wrote
and I want orient, how
are we doing on time?
I see a not good, Crystal.
- We're doing great on time.
(mumbles) information is really important,
so I want you to share it
with us and we go to 4:30,
so that we'll be-
- Okay, tamp me down.
I just share with you this
because I do think it's
something that's lost on,
you know, it's something I guess
I've come to see over time.
So I have patients that will ask me like
well, what do you think doc
is the best choice for me?
What do the studies show?
And so I share with you
this study that we did
so on the left-hand column I mean,
'cause probably don't recognize,
but these are large cohort studies.
So population-based studies
where they follow thousands,
sometimes tens of thousands
of individuals in the U.S.
that are really keyed on,
they're funded by the NIH,
the National Institutes of
Health, so taxpayer dollars
trying to figure out the core
etiology of heart disease.
Okay, so these are all the big ones
like Cardia, Jackson
Heart Study, Mesa, ENRICH,
you see them all there, okay.
And so we took all the
studies that follow people
for over two years, okay.
And we're intentionally designed
to study what are black-white
differences, okay.
And what we wanted to do was in particular
to how much mass incarceration
has impacted the validity
of these studies.
Okay, so we know that
based on earlier work,
there's about a one in three
lifetime risk of a black man
being incarcerated in this
country, over his lifetime.
Okay, and it's even higher,
the risk is higher in certain communities,
but it's one in three
population-based over in this country.
And so one of the questions
we wanted to know was
how often do these big population studies
actually go into prisons and jails?
How often do they include the
folks that are incarcerated?
And then let's say that
you recruit someone
in the community, a
young healthy black man
and then he gets picked up by the system,
do they actually follow him in?
And the problem with that is
the followup is really
important for these studies
because if you don't have followup
then you don't have internal validity.
You just can't make any
conclusions about black men
as a subcategory in these studies, okay?
And so what we found first
was these are the 25 biggest
studies that NHLBI funds.
How many of them crystal do you think
looked at incarcerated individuals?
I'm putting you on the spot now.
- No, no, you can't.
What, let's say 10% of
them maybe you get them.
- All right, zero, none, not a one, okay?
One of them Cardia asks one question.
It's been following people for 30 years.
I mean, all the stuff that
we know about heart disease
in young folks comes from Cardia.
There was a big thing
about how much marijuana
impacts your lung function
that's coming from Cardia.
Anything that has to do
with kind of cardiovascular
and pulmonary health from
NHLBI comes from these studies.
So zero go into prisons and
jails, one asks the question
and then none of them follow people
into prisons and jails either.
So then we just try to
estimate how much the loss
to follow up in these studies of black men
might be attributable to incarceration
because it couldn't actually measure it.
And it turns out it's a good bit,
so ranging from 15% and the lowest
I'll have to put the
lowest at 5% to Cardia
all the way up in black men to 25%, right?
So that 25% of the
estimated loss to follow up,
ugh, I'm actually not
amount reporting this well.
So red is the actual loss to up,
and this is how much of the loss to up
can be attributed to incarceration.
So in this study, it
looks like it's about 60%
of the loss of the black men.
And so it's just a good amount.
It's a significant amount in some studies
and what it speaks to me it's just that...
Oh, that's a picture, a
sketch of one of my patients
that he always loves me to
share it, it's Mark Baskerville
is that for this patient, he's Mark,
we just don't know much about his health.
Like when he comes down to it,
we don't know much about the
health of young black men.
We don't know much about
the health of men and women,
but in particular men that
passed through prisons and jails
and it's a huge hole in our knowledge.
And so what we've done
is just within our lab
is really tried to change that
and try to focus our questions
squarely on changing the narrative
around those who are incarcerated
and changing the questions that are asked.
And so, one of the
things I'm most proud of
is that we've pushed
ourselves to really diversify
who's here in our lab,
faculty on through students
have been directly impacted.
This is why I know so
much about hiring policy
and why then we worked to Ban the Box
because I'm always that person
that's trying to hire a person
with a criminal record into Yale
and so I've really gotten to
know the general council well.
And so the majority of our lab
has either been incarcerated
or has a family member
or multiple family members that
are currently incarcerated.
And we're focused on preventing
exposure incarceration,
mitigating the harms,
and then improving health and wellbeing
and really, we'll only
focus on interventions
that look at positive assets.
And mostly because those are the questions
that our lab members are interested in.
So, not surprisingly,
though like we're sick of these studies.
If we have to see another study
that pathologists black
people, we won't stomach it.
And so, the place I would say is for the
it's been the most growing
of the work that I've done
it's what keeps us all honest,
us all engaged in the
more complicated questions
that enables kind of more rich dialogue
about what needs to happen
and how it needs to happen.
It's not a space that I necessarily
demure all my experience,
but it is a space that where
there is kind of more richness
in the sorts of questions we ask
and then how we approach these questions.
And so, we also made a
commitment about five years ago,
just to try to get a big grant
in all major causes of death
and so have, I'm happy
to talk about these more,
but you know, that trials
or epi studies going on,
like Crystal, you alluded
to in these big domains.
And then the last thing
is that we recently
got awarded a large
grant looking at COVID-19
in the prisons and jails
and as I mentioned to you
also we'll have an aim of it
that's really focused
on looking at the history of pandemics.
And I kind of switch and end with this,
which is that I had the opportunity to do
it just finished this week to
co-chair a consensus report
for the National Academies of Science,
Engineering, and Medicine
of thinking about what
decarceration looks like
during COVID-19 in particular.
And, you know, we're in a profound place
where again, 90 out of the
10, 100 largest outbreaks,
cluster outbreaks of COVID
happened in prisons and jails
up until the colleges started opening
and now that it's being
taken over by colleges.
But prior to that, it
was in prisons and jails
and decarceration, depopulation
is a big piece of a tool
that can be used to
mitigate COVID transmission.
We've done some research that then
there's been a few other studies
that our team has done that.
And it's in that consensus report
that one of the primary recommendations
is focused on healthcare
and healthcare delivery.
You know, that in order
for us to be decarcerated,
in order for us to have a safe community
and I mean that in that kind of broadest,
maybe criminologist sense
like a public safety
that we have to expand our
notions of what safety looks like
and feels like.
And that has to include
notions of how the wellbeing
for people that are incarcerated
as well as the families
and communities to which they return.
And so I do think we're
in this profound moment.
I haven't been doing this for that long,
but at least more than a decade that,
who was willing to have
this conversation with me
has changed a lot and I'm grateful for it.
It's people that are surprising,
at least open to conversations
about how health systems,
physicians are part of,
well, I'll stop there
a revolution, you know?
And so I just appreciate
the time that y'all gave me
to go through these slides and pictures
because I do think what it
does do is that we've created
say like a third tier health system
that's out out of you, entirely out of you
and impacts so many,
so many people, their
families, and communities
and creates kinds,
I mean, it's no wonder that of course,
people are mistrustful
of the health system.
Look at this, you know?
And so it's incumbent
among us to look internally
and deal with our own stuff,
which is what I feel like
we have to do as physicians,
but also welcome opportunities
to collaborate across
especially Yale where there's
just the richness of scholars
really that can kind of inform
this work is mind blowing.
So, thank you.
- No, thank you, Emily.
That was really wonderful.
And I will start taking
questions in the chat as well,
but I do have a few and there were some
that actually came into the chat, already
and so I'll sort of pitch
some of those as well.
I know you're able to-
- (mumbles) Stop my screen share.
- I have a couple of questions
and to get us started,
but I'm hoping we could
start with this idea
of community-based participatory research
because it seems like it really
is the center and the heart
of what you're working
on and what you're doing.
And I'm wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about the principles of that
and if you could also
talk a little bit about
how your work and what you're doing
is impacting the New Haven community.
- Yeah, yeah, great.
So, there is a long rich tradition
of I'd say like a
participatory scholarship
and all just in that sentence.
Within the health sciences,
it mostly emerges when I think about it
through Barbara Israel's work
in University of Michigan
and so like the expansion of it.
And I would say like again,
this is just rooting it in the U.S.
within academic structures,
which is a wrong rooting
like that's flawed,
but in terms of scholarship,
that's looked upon.
It is Barbara Israel's work
and that's within the
University of Michigan.
And core to that, just to
distill it, I would say is this
that you will never come
to solutions of health
if you don't engage those
that are most involved
period, end.
And in doing so there's a long range,
so, you'll see a lot of work
and I think in medicine,
I think all of us can kind of as scholars
will look through the literature
and be like, oh people
labeling this community engaged
or participatory, blah-blah-blah.
So there's a scale is how I think about it
and at its most core,
fundamental, if you're thinking
about community-based
participatory research
how it's kind of fully actualize
the question comes from
the community itself.
And it's literally and then
with the question coming
from a community itself
it's in partnership, an
academic community partnership
that then one is a transfer of resources
and I mean, by that cash resources, one.
Two, a trading of knowledge and skill,
so that's more participatory, right,
but again that transfer
has to come from academics
to other community, right?
Three, it's partnership
throughout the process,
it's negotiated throughout the process,
it's discussed throughout the process,
but it means in the first
articulation the question
that comes from the community,
then you find out the research question,
then you figure out the
methods and protocols,
then you're actually implementing it,
then you're analyzing it
and that's a place where
there's a lot of kind of
like how many communities
actually have a statistician?
You know what I mean?
Like really to get to it,
so that's a place where
there's deep inequities
and same with the cash
and then the last is disseminating it.
But in its fullest articulation,
it is full participation
through the range.
And I have to say it's not easy to do,
so that's the first I'm gonna say.
I will say,
personally because the
structures don't permit it.
So funding structures, and
also kind of deep inequities
of like kind who can manage
and contractual obligations.
We have tried to literally, like,
yeah there's participatory
budgeting kind of
and I think ours is a
really well-funded NIH lab
and have worked and do
participatory budget.
We're really transparent around it
and what that means is talking
about really gross stuff,
which is how much indirect
CL takes off of grants,
how little communities will get,
how to support and build
that infrastructure
within community organizations
that they can even take
an indirect, right?
And that's where it has to go
in the deepest articulation.
And also that's really complicated.
We had one grant that we
were like, let's go 50, 50.
We're gonna give you 2.5 million,
we'll take the other 2.5 million
that means that all faculty
salaries are gonna be squished,
but we'll do it.
And there was no community organization
with the New Haven that could take it.
It's too much work to take
on a real kind of like
grassroots organization doesn't have
the accounting infrastructure to do that.
And so what that requires
are the infrastructures
within the EL to do that.
So we have a new office
of health equity research
with a new Dean, a good friend of mine,
Marcella Nunez-Smith,
I'm sure you'll know her.
And that's finally, finally,
we're gonna start trying to
build the infrastructure,
but it takes kind of that to
be able to do it, that's one.
And then the second I would say,
is that it's deeply
enriching of the science.
I can't tell you the number of times
where you're like, my God, we're an idiot.
We are asking all sorts
of the wrong questions
or if we'd gone for that
standard validated measures,
it would never have rolled out.
And so it's the place where people think,
oh, that's really nice, oh,
Emily's that left-leaning.
It's what makes the science more accurate,
more externally valid,
and internally valid.
So I really push back on
notions that this is some
kind of like left-leaning
progressive ways of including,
that's crap.
This is about the science and
it's about doing this right
and it's about shifting power
and also it's about making sure
that what it is that you discover together
actually is sustained beyond.
And so that's in the fullest articulation.
I'll just say this Crystal,
not everything should
always be participatory,
frankly, I think.
There are places and spaces to do so.
In my lab we'll be the first
to say, it's not easy work.
So there's stuff that
we just have to get done
and it's participatory, we're here kind of
but there's, we all have
our different expertise
and we're okay with that.
So that's the second thing I'll say
and then the work that
we're doing in New Haven.
So clinically within the SEICHE Center,
our grounding is our clinical work.
Like that informs everything
'cause otherwise you can't
keep yourself very real
even with lab members.
And so New Haven we have
a kind of a Transitions
Clinic Network of...
There's 45 programs across the country,
but there's three sites in Connecticut
and the research that we have
is mostly embedded within Connecticut.
It's where we have the
strongest relationships
where the assets are the greatest.
And so, I'll just point out
the participatory project
that we have on-going
and I'm looking at staff
who's been involved since really early on
and at least then the NIH grant.
So we had a nine year partnership,
a community academic partnership
that's been focused on gun violence.
And in particular thinking about
community-led interventions
that can mitigate and ultimately prevent
the community impacts of gun violence.
We were awarded an NIH
funding in that brief period
where they had kind of an
RFA focused on gun violence.
And what we've been able to do
is apply kind of a
social network analysis.
So there was a sociologist here
that I used to be here,
Andrew Papa Christos
that had a social network analysis
and did that using arrest data
and we tried to incorporate
health system data
into the social networks of gun violence.
And we took his data and what
we were really interested
like I said earlier is a
positive deviants model.
So, all sorts of folks are
focused on this high risk people.
Who I'm interested in are the people
that actually are looking
like they're high risk
and never get shot.
What are they doing right,
what's helping them?
the spaces in the community.
There's lots of places that look like
they should have had a ton
of shootings and they didn't,
statistically, right?
What's going on right?
And so we use that social network analysis
and this is all in partnership.
I'm telling you, we've
gone nine years with it
and this is the group that we're
trying to give out the cash
and they couldn't do it.
So they're like, oh my God, another grant.
I'm like, come on, where could they?
So then did qualitative interviews
of either individuals or those places
where things are working
or the places where nothing's happening
and Steph led a lot of that work.
And then now are using
both quantitative data
from New Haven, the interviews
and using this thing called
systems dynamic modeling.
So it's kind of newer in medicine,
not a lot of folks are using,
but it's a way of building a model,
a computer simulated model
where you create inputs that give
where you put in local data, okay.
And then can simulate and
dialing up and dialing down
different factors that
might impact gun violence.
So for instance,
okay, and I'll just give you
an example from our work.
The process starts with something called
group participatory modeling
where basically this community
academic partnerships,
so they've now gotten
all used to the terms
have to really think hard about
what are the different inputs
that cause gun violence
in our community and in
particular not about gun violence,
but the trauma that lingers?
Okay, so they create this model
and one of the big things on there
let's say is green spaces, okay.
And that's been born
out in the literature,
so of course these folks
have thought about it,
but there's a good rich
empiric science behind it.
And then you put it in your model
and what you can do using New
Haven data is just saying,
what if we tweaked up green
spaces in New Haven by 20%,
what happens to rates of gun violence?
And so now the community members
can see this model, use it,
think about the factors that
they think are important
to tweak up and tweak down.
And part of what we're trying to identify
are interventions that could
be community led entirely,
not dependent on government,
not dependent on police.
That they could lead on
their own to take action
to take hold of something that
they urgently need interventions
like every government cycle
and every budget shortfall
or whatever they're done with that.
It's complicated and I just grant cycles
of three years of five years
and we're now at that place
where we're coming up
with the intervention
and it's both exciting, but it's also,
sometimes science is
slow, it gets old, right?
The rates of gun violence are
going up and I tire of it,
but I also just remind myself
that if we don't do this well and right,
that I think it's gonna be the same crap.
We just don't have
solutions that are actually
with rigorous evidence behind
it that'll end up being scaled
and then we end up with more of the same,
which is like, if we tiled
down police, dial up police,
community led police.
And it's not to say that those solutions
I mean, that's not the
conversation I entertained
that's for somebody else.
Our lab is squarely focused on
what works within communities
and how can community leaders
kind of envision their
own safety and own health.
- This is amazing, Emily
and I'm learning a lot.
And I wanna bring in a few
of the other questions-
- Yeah, sure.
- They range, so I'm
trying to consolidate some.
But there was a question about
when you were talking about
health as a constitutional right
and someone asked explicitly
about mental health
and how that factors in to
folks who are incarcerated.
Is mental health apart of
that constitutional right
and what does it look like in the prisons?
- Yeah, so I don't know the court case,
but yes, it is part of
that constitutional right.
And then I will say,
healthcare throughout prisons and jails,
there's a one, a real
heterogeneity to that care
and two, we just don't know.
It's like what we know is that anecdotal,
but what I've seen also over time,
and I've seen really I
think like easily thousands
is that prisons and jails
are in and of themselves
trauma inducing.
And for people that have had either
go into prisons and jails
for mental health disorders
or have had significant traumas
and the life course of people
that have been incarcerated
is predominantly, incredibly
challenged, incredibly violent
and then to enter spaces
that are also violent
in their kind of existence.
Yeah, I think if there
are solid literature
around kind of the health impacts
of actually being in the carceral system
it's around mental health
outcomes and it's terrible.
And so to get into the nitty gritty,
what I would say though, is
it is really complicated.
To make, I don't know if I
should go into this tangent,
but to make a mental health diagnoses
and I'll just use the example of psychosis
like having kind of a...
And you know, I'm an internist,
so I'll just say that this
is not like a psychiatrist
would be like, she's not
really doing it justice.
But to just say this is that,
oftentimes making the
diagnoses within prisons
and different diagnoses in community,
it's just very difficult.
So, there's a clear-cut way
of diagnosing high blood pressure, right?
But there isn't a, you know,
even though there's guidelines
of like a DSM-5 criteria
and we go through it
kind of the conditions
of the system inside
and oftentimes people
have used an illicit drug
while they're outside really,
really affect those diagnoses
and so there's just so much disconnect
between these health systems.
It's a person will be on
a mental health, you know
drug, treatment, engaged in
care, outside in the inside
not be seen in the same
way, you hear them saying,
and vice versa, drug, treated,
engaged in care, come home
and they're like, we don't see.
And so I think it's just
like, I can't imagine,
like I would just be so frustrated
'cause you're like I was doing well here
and then now I've come
in and there's nothing
and or I was doing well inside actually
and that does happen.
Like I've just shared with
you guys, it's against,
it's counter to what we think,
but some people's health,
it's not to say that we
should incarcerate people,
but some people's help
actually are managed,
surprisingly when they actually have food
and a roof over their heads.
So it managed better and then come home
and they're just so aggravated
by not having Medicaid,
not having Medicare,
losing their benefits,
they're homeless, et cetera.
So that is a really
complicated place in part,
because of real breaks and care
in part by kind of who the providers are,
how they see the person,
and how they see kind
of severity of illness
in the certain circumstances.
- Thank you.
Now I have a question, it's quite there
it's specific around someone
who's been doing stuff
with the Connecticut Bail Fund hotline.
And one of the things that
they're hearing a lot about is
where in prison physicians
are sometimes complicit
and punishing people and withholding care
and things like that.
And the person is wandering,
is there something that the lab
or the center is gonna do to
address some of those issues
that are happening within prisons?
- I guess, what I would say is that
what we do clinically is, if
we see a patient in our clinic
and then we see bad care
that, of course, it's incumbent upon us
to then talk to the provider, figure out,
and see what it is that we do.
Within a research, that's not a place
that we're actively investigating
and places that but I do think
it's of critical importance.
I think oversight is, as
I indicated there's not.
Right, there's no mandatory
oversight, it blows my mind.
We just kind of absolved
ourselves of responsibility.
We don't wanna see it, we
don't wanna care about it.
It just, I can't believe that,
as a community, this is
something that we stand for it,
but it is not a place of
active advocacy right now,
for our center.
The things that we're really focused on
partially because of
where we think we're gonna
have the most leverage
and maybe this is just strategic
and also just the real deep
importance of decarceration
is trying to change compassionate release
like trying to really shore
up the science around it,
try to change the policies.
It's almost impossible to get a person
to be released in this country.
And the consensus report
we just did from NISM
said that one of the things
that is clear is that about 20,
the jail populations are down about 22%,
pre COVID and post COVID,
but the state prison
population is down only 4%.
And even in settings where the executive,
the governor, et cetera, wanted
to release, it's hard to do.
The compassionate, at least
policies are too specific,
too discretionary, really difficult to do
to actually see it through
and so these are the things
that we're working on.
- And I had another question
here, I'm gonna read it, okay.
It said, it's been
striking to me how so much
of the conservative political
discussions around healthcare
this year with the
conservative politicians
and protestors reactions
to mask in the pandemic
and in general regarding
conservative rejections
of Obamacare.
Employees the language of force
and encouraging on Liberty.
It's been especially striking this year
against the juxtaposition of incarcerated
and detained individuals
whose health has actually been threatened
by the limitations of
their liberty and mobility.
What reconceptualization
of health, public health,
the common good, and freedom,
do you see as necessary
to change in public conversations
and politics around
health in this country?
- Well, I have to say, I don't know who,
and I'm gonna say her.
This person (indistinct) Gina Moore,
but I'm just gonna say this.
Man, if you had an idea,
you got to share it
because I think that that's literally
what we spend our time thinking most about
is how can we make this an
issue that is everyone's issue.
I guess like the ways
that we've thought about
it is that core to us is as I shared,
and I think I'm reminded daily.
There's a deep urgency to this work
and it's urgent from some
people more than others,
but I feel like because I see patients
and then my lab has always that it's,
this is a matter of survival, right?
And so trying to think about
the right sorts of questions
to expand this to include
others, I think it's important.
It also, I think is, should I say this?
It's not a surprise, I also,
I think it's slightly loathsome too
that there's increased interest
in thinking about
criminal justice policies
given the opioid epidemic.
And focus now that white communities,
rural communities are interested.
These are places of urgent intervention.
It's also a place where we feel like,
well, then we just have
to be strategic about it.
And so I think our lab
really thinks hard about
how it is that we can
broaden the conversation
include more people we've been at
increasingly some of the research
that you'll see coming out of our lab
is focused on families.
There's beautiful work done
by Chris Waldman's team
in Cornell, where he finally
created a national estimate
of how many people have a family member
that's been exposed to incarceration.
And so in this country I don't
know if y'all have seen it,
but it's almost half, right?
And then among black family,
black communities it's even higher.
And so we've done a study
using the data our FAM has
I think he's publicly shared it.
And we've embedded in the
measures of wellbeing.
And what we found was
that pretty profound,
but even if you had an
extended family member,
that's incarcerated a cousin,
a godparent, whatever,
your wellbeing is worse than those
that have never had a person
with a history incarceration
and this wellbeing measure that we use
translates to life expectancy.
I think lot of it is just thinking about
the other stakeholders that
are impacted, family members.
One of our team members is now again,
within the context of COVID,
starting to think about kind
of correctional officers.
So I recently learned that their mean,
I don't know if this should be quoted
because I don't know
this to be a true fact,
but I heard that mean
life expectancy is 66,
so it's crazy low.
And I think it's because they work
in toxic stressful environments.
The same toxicity that our
patients feel, they feel too
and it's a way of also
bringing in other people
into the conversation,
COVID is doing that for us.
So it's trying to bring into
the conversation other people
who haven't always been
in the conversation
of how it is that we decarcerate.
And so we're really trying to work on that
and where we're best is
both doing the research
and then trying to think
about more legal avenues now
of trying to expand that conversation.
- Emily, I also was wondering,
there was another question that came up
and I may ask you additionally,
but I wanna ask it
because somebody asked the
question and it had to do with
I'm not sure if there was
something behind the question,
but they wanted to know
specifically about asthma
and I'm not quite sure,
but they may have been some logic in it
that I just missed
because I think you were talking
about a lot of the things
that incarcerated people were suffering
and it may be an environmental question,
but there was a question that asks,
how many, I've gotta see if I can find it,
but how many people, are
there a lot of people
who are incarcerated who
are suffering from asthma?
- Yeah, it is a great question.
And let me just see if I can just pull up,
so it's a great question.
So what I can say about
it right off the cuff
is that people that are incarcerated
have higher rates of asthma
compared to the general population.
In fact, they have higher
rates of hypertension,
they have higher rates of heart disease,
and then certainly have hepatitis C.
So people that have been incarcerated
have kind of disproportionately
higher rates.
And then look at got this,
I'm gonna just share the screen, so yeah.
Here we go.
- Yeah, she-
- You don't see that?
- No, I don't see, it's coming up.
There we go.
- Okay, there we go.
And these are data that are taken
again from a Bureau of
Justice Statistics survey.
You know, I just realized
I had never kind of defined this though
this might be just real
basic for you guys,
but jails and prisons are different,
so jails house those people
that are waiting judicational crimes
or serving sentences of less than a year
and then prisons house those
that have been sentenced
typically for sentences
longer than a year.
And so these data come from the
Bureau of Justice Statistics
and so what you can see
here last row here asthma is
that it's 14.9% in the prison population
compared to the general population at 10.2
and the jail population
is 20.1 compared to 11.4.
And these are data from 2011 to 2012,
but are probably, they'd be the same here.
It's disproportionately higher.
And as is the case for
many chronic conditions
cervical cancer, it goes on and on.
- And we are running close to time,
so I'm gonna ask the final question.
And the question is what can,
and this is a big question,
but I think it's an important
question and what people,
and one of my students are out one
that my students are always asking me
is what can we do, right?
What can we do to support this work?
And what's at stake if we
don't in some ways, right?
So in some ways I'm
just, it's that kind of,
I feel like you've presented us with
what feels like a call to action.
When I see the photos and I
hear how you talk about them
I'm like, okay, we've got
it, we got to move on this.
And so us in the community
of African-American Studies
what can we do to support this work?
- Well, it's interesting,
I have to say this.
I only recently started reading history
of the Freedman's Bureau
and it's in that reading that I realized
it's a deeply challenged history.
It was the first,
if I'm understanding national
health system in our country
and was grossly underfunded
and has so many deep parallels
because it was essentially a
second class healthcare system
for certain sorts of people,
you know, former slaves.
And it's similar,
like we've constructed a whole
other operating health system
that is totally out of you,
that's financed by our collective dollars
that we've just thrown it away.
And it has differential impacts
across kind of our communities,
but it's a place that I think
really requires deep inquiry now.
What I'm interested in seeing
are kind of how health help,
how doctors help allied professionals
like how are we complicit in
that, bringing that history,
Where are places?
I just haven't seen, and
again I just added myself,
which is like I've just newly
started reading about
the Freedmen's Bureau.
So you hear what I'm saying,
it's maybe that there's a ton out there,
but when we turn to our
colleagues within history
and legal scholars and
then even Miriam Rich,
who's at the history of
medicine with in Yale
there isn't a lot as far as she can tell.
And she's a scholar of mass incarceration
and the intersections of help
of how physicians are
complicit or haven't been,
how have they been revolutionary?
We need narratives that help
kind of make this our own issue.
And so I kind of would turn
it to you, which is that
I think with the work that
you do is illuminating.
It gives us a grounding
for what is possible,
what had been possible,
what's deeply flawed.
It also makes us realize
like in turning to a
historical perspective,
this stuff isn't new,
I mean, just isn't now.
You know it's like kind of popped up again
and for me, I think
especially for generations
of new med students
they think, oh my gosh,
this is the first time and
its own, and we just have to
I think that there also
gonna be stories out there
within history of solutions
of radical uprisings
and ways that physicians,
ways that health systems
or more grassroots health systems
have come up to fight this.
And to me, those stories have to be told
for us to kind of embrace
a fuller and richer
and create a more honest
narrative of who we are,
how we are as help communities,
and how we've really have never
cared for black people in this country?
I just invite you guys to step
foot into prisons and jails.
That to me is like, I feel
like the first time I did it,
I just couldn't turn back.
And then I've been to prisons and jails
all over now, the world
and so I have to say it doesn't matter
and it's just so deeply.
We've created a system that really,
and I don't know,
the last patient I just felt
come home from prison was 75,
spent 40 years inside.
I mean, that just can't be this, you know?
40 years inside during COVID.
So I guess that that's what I'd say
is there's a lot to be done.
Doctors are real pragmatic, I guess,
so I'm like, well, there's
stuff that you can do now later,
but I think like for me, I mean,
and then we welcome kind of,
come over to our side of the campus.
There's a lot going on here and we have,
I look at Crystal, but
you know we've developed
and have growing relationships,
certainly with folks on the FIS side.
But our strongest reach
right now at the law school,
but would love real
partnerships across Yale
because I do think like,
especially just thinking about
who's coming next step
in your Endeavors series.
I mean, this is a place
where I think Yale has
many, many assets to offer.
How we reimagine and reshape conversations
around what a decarcerate
system looks like.
- Thank you, I think
that is a powerful note
to end on an amazing invitation,
particularly to our graduate students
who are doing creative
and imaginative work
on policing, on the environment,
and how the carceral state
has impacted black lives.
And that I know that some
of them after the day
will be drawn to the center
and I will encourage them
and my colleagues to
engage in a conversation
with you and your work.
So again, thank you for
sharing this with us,
we've learned so much.
I'm gonna ask people to unmute
in this moment before you go off
and we're gonna do a clap that
you can actually hear, right?
Instead of,
(claps)
So iF people will unmute and clap
that would be great.
Thank you so much.
(chimes)